you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive no funny business
these are dangerous people team two is
clear to go
fire uh three two what are you guys
doing
what you we're here to save you you were
gonna save me it was a really good plan
too well i can go back inside and you
can still do it that's patronizing i'm
so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for funk's sake here's the deal
we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early
although that isn't an open invitation
for you to cough without covering your
mouth
what's the plan how the hell am i
supposed to know you're the leader
you're supposed to be decisive and i've
decided that you should eat a big bag of
dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem why
would someone put
penises all over the beans who knows why
mad men do what they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
don't you worry i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
oh my god we've got to freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
[Music]
i love the rain like angels are
splooting all
over us